[Music]
three months after the events of the
first three Resident Evil game comes
Resident Evil Code Veronica this Ward is
going to be difficult to get in three
minutes so I'm sorry if I overrun a
student Claire Redfield returns as a
main protagonist and is once again
searching for her brother Chris she
uncovers an umbrella facility in Paris
but during her infiltration she has
captured and imprisoned when she wakes
up she's behind bars somewhere off the
coast of South America in an institution
known as Roquefort Island Claire is
unexpectedly freed by umbrella security
guard Rodrigo after a surprise T virus
outbreak on the island has quickly
caused the facility to be overrun by the
undead Claire finds fellow inmate Steve
Burnside and the two worked together to
find a way off the island
Claire is almost killed by umbrella
commander Alfred Ashford and his sister
Alexia but survives the encounter their
readiness hold it right there
Steven finds his father but he's already
part of the undead horde but he can't
bring himself to kill his own flesh and
blood Steve's dad makes a beeline for
Claire which prompts him into action
albert wesker the central antagonist in
the entire Resident Evil universe drops
in and revealed it was he go unleash the
virus on the island and once again
Claire looks like she's about to die and
once again she somehow survives Albert
thinks about killing our hero but
changed his mind after a mysterious
phone call maybe of some I'm going to
let you live a little longer Alfred and
Alexia Ashford are revealed to be the
same person
Alexia passed away almost 15 years ago
and Alfred the way to cope with his
sister's death has to become the
cross-dressing bipolar schizophrenic he
is today and who said resident evil is
an educational glutton Steve escaped the
island but just when they think their
troubles are over
Alfred pops up crashing their plane into
yet another umbrella facility this time
in the Antarctic
are you alright
another encounter with Alfred leaves the
seventh Earl of Ashford dead and even a
fight was the appli name not for our to
cannot stop Claire right things are
going to get a little confusing now
Alfred somehow survived his fall and his
dead sister well Alexia is actually in
cryogenic sleep as an attempt to subdue
elements of the t veronica virus she
possesses so the T virus is back but now
it has a Veronica story with it as well
okay sticking with me Alfred frees his
sister and dies in her arm meanwhile
Chris Redfield arrives at rockbot and
meets Wesker the two scuffle and we
learn that Wesker is now a superhuman
who is stronger and faster than Chris in
every way just as Wesker is about to
kill Chris Alexia pops up on the screen
laughing your little head off and once
again Wesker turns down the opportunity
to kill a Redfield and instead gets his
backside to the Antarctic quickly
pursued by Chris after months of looking
for each of our Chris and Claire finally
finds one another and share a lovely
little Norman
of course this moment is interrupted by
Alexia who was now infected Steve with
the T Veronica virus Steve mutates and
his hell-bent on killing Claire but
manages to fight the virus just in the
nick of time he D mutates is that even a
word and announces his love for Claire
before joining his dad in the afterlife
Alexia once again battles our hero but
he's taken out by a plasma weapon Chris
and Wesker face off one more time but a
small explosion saves Chris while this
was all happening Wesker's men record
Steve's body which is now infected with
the T Veronica virus which could see C
return in the future finally Chris and
Claire narrowly escape the facility in a
jet moments before it blows up
so that's it that's Resident Evil Code
Veronica in three minutes
ish next up is Resident Evil zero a
prequel to the original Resident Evil
game oh please do as a favor like and
subscribe because that was harder work
than it looks
I'm not over PlayStation grenade see you
next time